hello and welcome to see do play I am
Nino Taurus with that am Luis Torres
okay yeah close to that 2,400 mark again
sure it's amazing how many players
choose that bad line with be six after
that black has a very hard time to
equalize and probably it's not possible
anymore let's see ah threatening me five
him down okay
just be quick here maybe five
immediately was possible this also makes
a good impression okay um just taking on
yeah probably i just take play for ya
for peace play um so 95 or not 95 g6
it's not so clear what I'm doing next
and interesting question is some you see
really threatening to take probably he
is yeah I don't like to play Knight to
e5 here after d6 there is no
particularly convincing continuation
don't see anything at least maybe
Queenie too but before I do anything
else I need to really badly take a
bathroom break I usually do that before
the games but i forgot that i started
this game or requested the game so small
break in the recording yeah so back from
that all-important bathroom break and
yeah i really didn't play that so well
right this is not that brilliant
yeah probably five was Miss time Tom
he can just take g3 for example and be
well maybe I can take with the f pawn
this is making some sense actually maybe
I can still play for something here due
to them we can light squares hmm yeah I
definitely will take with the f porn if
it decides to capture but he's one of
those deep thinkers so my my break costs
some time but I'm still the head on the
clock briar mile threaded taking it to
extremes i mean also i'd like to take
one time but ok this one so 95 of course
yeah i know they have porno I guess
yeah it's not easy huh that's not an
easy position night always looks at g6
g4s a part of this and the night only 5
is just an annoying piece always looking
at the g7 porn so there is no Queen g5
or something available yeah so here I
can play 96 win the pawn I think always
there something better knight c6 26 okay
now I'll go for the simple the simple
play and just wonder let's just take
just take take upon 9700 and 95 check
maybe not the best continuation but it's
not bad
want to play Knight h5 possible Oh what
he allows er the discover check here wow
isn't this on check maybe 97 was
stronger lack writer but okay that's
that's enough yeah still I didn't didn't
play the opening well I think if I've
was maybe not well timed oh yeah the
engine actually likes it and here wants
to play it doesn't want to take yeah
yeah okay their computer is right of
course as long as the point is here this
night is looking really awful I have a
somewhat like a turbocharged samish
variation here in some way d 5 is a move
for Queenie to is a move this is this is
helping black 97 looks normal Queenie to
yeah yeah this is what the computer is
suggesting but I didn't like the six I
felt that if I trade too much stuff here
this is some right actually not so bad
for me but that felt a little bit meek
so this is why I went here now yeah yeah
the engine things black is okay and
gives squeegee 5 quite nice yeah
probably operating with those ideas so I
cannot take here night f4 for example
it's good so this is what the computer
wants me to do and says black is okay
yeah understandable so this was the best
defense and after this year is probably
in trouble they have much control one's
already losing according to the comp
it even gives neither for you and I
don't think this is particularly bad
netting a pawn it's pretty awful ok
didn't need to blunder this one but the
position was very difficult to play ok
thanks for watching